and this video i mean it's just uh
it's just wild man we're going to play
this video okay i don't know if do we
have desktop audio uh pulled up it's the
second or last on the mixer board just
in case
because i don't know if we set up
desktop audio for playback just yet i
think we do but let's play and we'll see
what happens he just happens to stumble
in okay wait okay all right i'm gonna
play this but i wanna give you some
context
this is washington free beacon saying
binger says that all rose and bob rosen
rosenbaum did the night of the shooting
was
let me just play for you as he reads off
this list when i heard this video i
screamed i was like wow i'm like in the
vehicle when he said it watching this
live check this out
he just happens to stumble into it so
what does he do that night
oh let me tell you all the awful things
joseph rosenbaum did he tipped over a
porta potty
that had no one in it
he swung a chain
he lit a metal garbage system dumpster
on fire
oh and there's this empty wooden flatbed
trailer that they pulled out in the
middle of the road and they tipped it
over to stop some bearcats and they lit
it on fire oh my god right here right
here oh and he said some bad words right
here said the n-word
okay listen just positive
america america okay america all right
for all the woke supremacists out there
you got you got this white attorney
playing down the use of the n-word being
used by another white guy using the
n-word at a so-called a so-called
anti-racism gathering in kenosha does
that make sense to any of you out there
does it to me okay so for quick context
for those just tuning in this is the
prosecutor in the kyle rittenhouse case
trying i think
to downplay the actions of joseph
rosenbaum who was
i got to be very careful about this
a person who committed some of the most
serious atrocities against children and
i do believe that matters in this case
and should have been relevant because he
just got out of jail and that played a
role in why he yelled i don't care if i
go back to jail but i digress we'll get
to that later
it seems like vinger the prosecutor is
trying to downplay as if to say he only
did these things and then he got killed
and let me i got to point out
he he slowly escalates it it's like dude
start with the worst thing and end with
the lighter thing
start with like well he did he did
participate in burning up a trailer in
the middle of the street but then what
was he really doing on his own he
knocked over a port-a-potty okay it's
bad but there was no one in it no he
starts at the lightest and escalates to
the point where i'm like what he's like
he knocked over a porta potty i'm like
that's pretty bad but like i've seen
pranksters do that as long as nobody in
it well and he left out what happened
because he said oh he lit a metal
dumpster on fire no it was on fire and
he was attempting to push it into
occupied police vehicles with human
beings inside of them and there there
there were people pushing dumpsters
towards a gas station i want to be
careful how i phrased that because
whether they were trying to i can't read
their right it was like down the road
past the gas station they were moving in
the direction of the gas station but
some set and then the fire got put out
but hold on he goes from there he's
letting a dumpster on fire and i'm like
whoa whoa okay that's getting pretty
dangerous what human can get away with
that you can't get away with that stuff
do you remember when the judge
when when they were in pre-trial uh
motions he was like
we shouldn't be able to call them
arsonists all he did was set a dumpster
on fire and the judge goes are you
kidding me
arson that's arson
hold on hold on then he says he was
swinging a chain it's like hold on yo
last i checked fires make more fires
that's like really bad and swinging a
chain
you can kill somebody doing that so he's
escalating and then he's like oh and
then he took a wooden trailer and
flipped it over in the street and set it
on fire to block the police and i'm like
yo that's like really bad like that's
blocking emergency service is bad that's
accidentally killing people bad and to
top it all off with the cherry on top
he's screaming the n-word over and over
again cool yo it sounded to me like the
prosecutor was trying to lose
and so i tweeted this the ada kraus the
other prosecutor did a much much better
job than binger people got mad that i
tweeted they're like are you kidding
he's flopping and i'm like i didn't say
he was doing a good job that guy was
doing that guy would laugh at me he
would laugh at me anytime i would say
antifa
rioter arson vandalism and looting he
would laugh at me and just shake his
head like that and i'm like what are you
laughing at
that's funny to you that's why i'm
saying the jury's seeing that stuff
because people are gonna people know
what happened in kenosha and when people
are sitting there laughing at what
happened to their town they're not gonna
happen there there were people who are
super chatting to us uh in response to
your testimony so i guess i don't know
if it's true i don't accuse worker of
saying it but people were saying on
rocket stream they were saying you were
a bad witness and i think some of it has
to do with you came off as adversarial
with the prosecutor right i think he
came off as adversarial with me because
i didn't come in with that mentality i
came in here's the thing and people may
not know this is i submit my footage and
i was willing to cooperate with both of
them
he did not have to approach me that way
but he chose to because he wanted to
make it seem like it was adversarial but
i kept stating over and over again i'm
willing to tell both sides the truth and
i'm here for the jury i personally i'm
not a lawyer so i can only defer i think
raketo does a great stream if you guys
haven't been watching his streaming
stuff the commentary is absolutely
fantastic hearing all these lawyers tell
you about what's right what's wrong and
when you have like
10 lawyers who are watching they can
point out all of the mistakes being made
it's great it's kind of unfair to the
actual defense team because they don't
have the privilege of having 10 other
lawyers advising them or whatever but
anyway it was a great stream but but i
will say i actually thought you i i
think he may have gotten you the
prosecutor in that regard i think you're
right
he knew that you were a fact witness on
the ground and you were
very good for the defense so we had to
try and figure out a way to make it seem
adversarial you being confident in what
you were talking about
he does this really annoying thing where
he was like um
oh who do you work for
you uh don't
don't aren't you being biased it's like
a very annoying and condescending
because he wants you to be like
hey hey look this is what happened so
that he can make it seem like you're not
credible that being said i thought
one thing that you said
was the most important bit of testimony
that people shouldn't gloss over when
you brought up that cal right now came
out and de-escalated the violence
because we can make we we can question
the actions that night all day we can
say should kyle have run did he point
the rifle they're trying to claim this
video and we can have an argument over
the facts surrounding rosenbaum chasing
him
but when you brought up that you
witnessed kyle say please you know i i
mean uh i'm perfect i'm i'm using a
metaphor like when he came out trying to
calm people down that says to me there
is no way you can argue intentional
homicide well here's another point and
this is why i don't care about any of
the lawyers that are doing their live
streams critiquing me and any of that
none of that means anything to me
the reason why is because not only was i
there to share my eyewitness testimony i
was there to submit more than 80 to 100
videos that corroborate every single
thing that i said everything that i said
and i don't care who has them
on planet earth right now other than
those jurors and that's why i was there
and i have faith in the jurors that they
were going to listen to my testimony and
they have all of those videos to take a
look at what really happened at least on
my part from my heart from my
perspective in my own life my own
conscience that's what that was my
intention to be there for this case i
was
i was flabbergasted
how often the prosecution lied
binger and krause and their closing
arguments kept lying and and some of it
was just falsehoods which could be
accidental but some of it was outright
lies completely contradicting what the
judge said there is no duty to retreat
uh avoidance is not a category maybe i'm
wrong maybe i'm but i was watching this
and i even i even checked on this i
looked up to make sure
there's four categories i don't know
what the four categories are but some
states have a fifth avoidance i want
i've been reading andrew branca's law of
self-defense because he's a self-defense
expert but avoidance means in certain
places you have a duty to retreat not
wisconsin but they kept saying he had a
duty to retreat he should have he didn't
exhaust all methods he could have run
even though he did run but it was
amazing to watch them just outright lie
and i thought to myself how is it
that the prosecution the state is
allowed to lie to the jury when when the
defense would object this is the
craziest thing there was one point
where
binger has the rifle and he's explaining
that he pointed it you know because he
did this in more than one occasion i
guess but he he he pointed it at the
zaminski's
and then the the uh the defense objects
he's facing the wrong direction and
before the judge says anything bingo
goes that's an argument
and then the judge goes yeah that is an
argument and i'm like whoa the arrogance
of the prosecution
i don't understand how they can admit
cgi evidence which they did like this is
not a photograph they admitted computer
generated imagery of the night in
question
and then claimed that kyle written house
in a split second dropped a fire
extinguisher took off his weapon put the
strap back on it and then aimed with his
left hand with the with the chamber
right next to his face so it would eject
a cartridge into his face that's what
the prosecution claimed
i and then and the argument is i guess
the way the court works is well the
defense can just tell the jury that when
it's their turn and i'm like no way man
if you have a false statement of fact i
personally maybe i'm wrong because i
don't understand why they do it this way
and there's probably a good reason but
i'd imagine a good judge would be like
make your arguments but don't make up
your facts there are left-handed weapons
and it is true that you were facing the
wrong direction in your demonstration
you could make an argument about intent
about what kyle should have done but he
shouldn't be allowed to say there's no
such thing it was krav said there's no
such thing as a left-handed gun
of course there are latino guns there i
there's i i have uh um
which one is it what's what's my polish
makarov whatever it's a right-handed gun
it is specifically only a right-handed
weapon and there are left-handed weapons
i know because i have a right-handed gun
you literally you can hold it your left
if you are left-handed but it's
uncomfortable and it's not shaped
properly i just don't get it
maybe we should have a lawyer on to
explain to me why prosecution has been
allowed and maybe the real reason is
because the defense didn't object but
also bingo and i brought this up to you
guys before this show uh he makes
statements you're supposed to be asking
the witness questions but he will say
things like it seems to me that he
said that if you light a fire that he's
going to use his weapon is that correct
his question is is that correct
before he makes a giant statement about
what he believes is happening that to me
is court mouth it's malpractice i i
think the the the prosecutor is not
supposed to
makes directed statements to the
witnesses
it is and it's it's lazy uh law practice
when there have been a few instances
where the judge there's been an
objection
and like the defense said that's a
statement and then the judge goes ask a
question
that's common they'll do that but you're
right it is extremely lazy but it's
probably on the line where it's like
so ian
when you walked down the street you
really wanted to kick that dog
right
exactly it's like no i just said you
wanted to do it then asked you to agree
with me you know what i mean yes the
questions are do you agree do you agree
do you agree not not and this is i mean
it is so blatant at 116 39 or whatever
and i wish we had the video pulled up he
makes a long statement and they cut him
off in the middle of it before he has a
chance to say is that is that accurate
what channel are you on this is the
actual full video prosecutors
cross-examinate cross-examine kyle
rittenhouse on youtube
116 39 time stamp uh banger just goes
into a long statement and then they cut
him off and he's like i'll withdraw the
question they object to it and then he
says i'll withdraw the question in the
right after he just made a statement
it's not a question it's but it's a good
thing they objected and that's that's
the part of the process but even the
defender was like that's something
something the question the judge was
like yeah you can't they're like you got
to take back your question that was the
bad question it was like dude it was a
statement this is what the prosecution's
been doing they've been what he did to
me yes what he did to you their whole
case is predicated upon emotional
manipulation they claim drew hernandez
is this veteran reporter who knows what
he's talking about when it serves the
current argument for this minute and
then later on at the end of the argument
they say he's biased you can't believe
him when he kept like he would use and i
know lawyers do this but i think he just
was unaware that i would actually pick
up on it like he would say things like
so this video you posted um that you
made on and he would continue like no i
didn't make anything
oh and this was on video he's like oh
the video you recorded
yes i remember this matter so these
words matter because they could lead you
down a path to get you to admit to
something without even realizing because
he was trying to what he was doing was
you had two clips
you you had one you had one moment
captured on two different cameras so you
basically just put one and then the
other right
and he tried using it to argue it was
manipulated videos he used the word
splice exactly that's why when he was
like you made the video he was trying to
get you that's why i'm like people need
to realize that i think i think you did
a good job i mean i'm sure there's some
things people could criticize you for
but if you went there told the truth you
were yourself that's all that matters
but he was he tried to say you made the
video and you caught him on that because
his line of questioning was you spliced
the video and you manipulated therefore
we should be allowed to use our
manipulated video as well but that's why
if you guys caught my response my
response was
there's full footage on the body cam and
the phone unedited i sent you all the
raw and i sent you this
synced video as well so the jury has all
of it the other thing he said was i
loved this because the night before you
testified i was like drew is not going
to take it from him he's not going to be
manipulated he's going to know what he
knows he's going to say what he said
because we've had you on the show i know
the kind of person you are and he said
you went down to kenosha to film the
things that were happening there and
you're like the violent riots yes yeah i
was like yeah
yeah because they're trying to they're
trying to emit that
from to keep it from the jury and they
need they need to know that this was not
some peaceful environment they they're
trying to paint this picture that you
know someone showed up to kenosha on
some random day and just decided to
shoot somebody or they're even trying to
say someone showed up to kenosha at a
peaceful protest and decided to shoot
somebody that's not true this is what's
getting me
at all from what i've seen i i can't
visualize the violence like like how
many buildings do you think got burnt
out uh i got to be careful with how i
answer these questions but there were
multiples
a hundred a thousand twenty a range
between fifteen and a hundred or they're
like between 100 and 500 i have no idea
something about single digits right yeah
yeah kenosha i i would have to look at
the see what they were they're about
single digits how many cars were burned
out i mean oh man they were not smashing
cars on camera they're just smashing all
the windows and destroying the car more
than 50 on the first car dealership the
car dealership was smashed out but not
burned out and i mean that this stuff is
so the first one they burnt they burnt
all those cars
the same thing happened in ferguson i
went we went and filmed this and it was
crazy it looked like fallout 3.
they went to the dealerships and they
poured there's video of them carrying
gas cans dude when i was in ferguson
this was scary not only were gunshots
going off but there was a point where we
were driving down the road and we saw
the people carrying the gas cans
and we were like
they were yelling and we just like keep
driving keep driving when you got
rioters walking up with gas cans guns we
were like we're not gonna we can't we
can't stop i don't i don't remember if
we got any footage of it we saw when we
were like this is where the danger level
is too high even for us because they
know we're reporters and that's where
bad stuff goes down i got shot at on
more than one occasion now i'm not no
one targeted me no one said hey look at
simple and pull the trigger i was part
of a group of journalists walking on the
street gunshots went off on more than
one occasion i had to drop to the ground
and it's not white supremacists doing
this it was black lives matter rioters
who were shooting guns randomly at these
events is it do they not call them
arsonists because they have to be
convicted of arson before you can call
someone an arsonist no no ian they're
peaceful protesters creating harmonious
chaos that of course we're speaking
towards the political agenda of the you
know nefarious global elite you know
that night that first night in kenosha
right in front of the courthouse to the
right uh there's a like a dinosaur
museum antifa showed up full black block
and they were getting little black kids
and they were they were like handing
them things in order to burn down
uh the museum and they broke the window
and they were trying to burn down the
building from inside the window this is
what these people do like they
infiltrate some of these movements and
they recruit certain people they'll give
them the shields they'll give them
equipment they'll give them an umbrella
they'll give them something to do in
order to commit some of their mass
violence and a lot of people are like
well is antifa really organized yeah
they are and sometimes they even do like
literally on the job training with
people that are just willing to commit
crimes thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time